guys there are plenty of place in
eSports that on their own are pretty
hype but then there are those truly
special moments that transcend or gain
all thanks to legendary caster calls all
right think about it for a second think
about your favorite playing eSports can
you really imagine that play without the
casting that went with it great casting
turns regular good plays into iconic
moments in eSports and today we're gonna
be ranking them here are the top 10
casting calls in eSports history kicking
off our list is the iconic battle cry
that led OD to their very first TI title
the sub call from TI 8 o G made an
incredible comeback in Game four of the
ti 8 Grand Finals but it was sev who put
the final nail in lgd's coffin an OD
pixel immortalized subs truly incredible
acts call with a call of his own then
can you do it head lose it all
[Applause]
Justin Wong's illustrious career has
given us tons of iconic moments one in
particular earns the number nine spot on
our list justin wong is the king of
Marvel vs. Capcom 2 but at evo 2007
Yipes pushed him to his limit down to
only Cyclops with three characters to
bring down Justin took Yeates for a ride
and Kris Kalyan made sure that the
audience knew that it's never over til
it's over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
coming in at the number 8 spot is a call
that has essentially become the national
anthem of dota 2 and I am Katowice 2018
fnatic made an incredible comeback
against secret and the casting was
pretty good now they jump in deep for a
total Fe BKB will protect him a line to
seal a lot of Democrats Don is going the
pace but this is the problem yet the
throne is going down bad guys lap saw
Johnson good by pie light died and
goodbye eternal and me but over on the
Filipino stream lawn and do know we're
taking things to a whole new level the
DOTA community rallied around the calm
on a tog turning it into a meme it
became a chat wheel option and Lord
Gaiman himself even gave us his best
laqad mata tog on the biggest stage dota
has to offer Canadian neighbors putting
on an event like this when you have
people coming from 64 different nations
is really challenging so
number seven on our list is probably the
single-most game defining commentary of
all time no single commentator has
delivered the bars quite like Yipes and
the now legendary marvel baby video is
his ps2 dizzy sauce
Yipes commentary became canon for marvel
players everywhere from haagen-dazs to
scoops to Pringles
Yipes gave the fgc so much with just one
video coming in at the number 6 spot on
our list is the moment Kobe brought any
League of Legends fans together with a
perfect call an a League of Legends is
well it's not always up to par when it
comes to the international stage
so when msi 2016 rolled around some
people weren't expecting too much from
CLG but kobe and all the NA diehards
back home believed
I never down at them CLG counter logic
gaming with the most unlikely victory
holy crap taking the number five spot on
our list is perhaps the most
embarrassing moment in eSports history
immortalized by the perfect call
unbelievable
well she gay is gonna be dreaming about
that tonight at Evo 2015's guilty gear
winner semi-finals will she gay and
Ogawa faced off and a pretty close match
woah she gay clutched out an incredible
win in the second round of Game three
and he got so excited that he forgot
something important the match wasn't
over so smart he couldn't burst because
of the super
[Applause]
[Applause]
was over and gave him hell book it's
called was so iconic that he even
received mainstream media attention Oh
gah WA won the semifinal match
eventually won the Evo tournament as I
said the world tournament yeah the world
one of the tournament's the number four
spot on our list goes to one of the most
iconic plays in CS history
Happy's legendary deagle ace it's three
Mac London 2015 envious are playing
against TSM and they're forced to eco
TSM is heading to be site and the only
person standing between them and the
round is happy and deagle CSM they're
scared about this there they aren't
rushing this time around they're taking
their sweet time hoping to catch
somebody Picon envious side and well
that's what happens when you go around
the corner happy with juan deag
[Applause]
the breeze like sweating bullets
similar couldn't even comprehend what
was happening and delivered one of the
most iconic calls and csgo history even
though we broke his chair while he was
doing it I think I just broke my chair I
might need a new one
yep I think I actually did this break my
chair hold on let me get into it a worth
you sacrifice a chair for a round that's
gonna go down in history without a doubt
here coming in at the number three spot
is a play that yes we know we know we've
put on a million top-10 lists before but
we still can't get enough of it it's
cold zeros legendary jumping op I have
no words to describe ridiculous stuff
that's the most ridiculous thing I've
ever seen at the MLG columbus major semi
finals luminosity had their backs
against the wall down 59 against liquid
it looked like the map was pretty much
over but then cold did the impossible
and DDK couldn't even believe what he
was seeing
he's gotta hit these shots we saw
Polhemus in his spot before the same
spot but but with much more utility to
work with
here he comes once again the first base
is the trainees gonna hit the ground
they're as cold
koan the same luminosity with your play
unthinkable seems there on the be
apartments they need a huge play without
something I'm never gonna see ever again
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
the single most iconic call in League of
Legends history
League of Legends was a different place
in 2013 hasn't changed you can always
count on the play is incredible but what
truly elevates it is Doe is casting even
standing out in the cold in the rain he
still delivered a call that has gone
down in eSports history many caster
calls are courted within one games
community but only one transcends the
game it started in and sees others adopt
the call as their own it's the wombo
combo and it's taking the top spot on
our list
[Music]
[Music]
the play itself is amazing to watch and
it's easy to laugh at Poor's ooh getting
double-teamed but homemade waffles took
it to the next level with a performance
that's almost operatic but the most
incredible thing is that homemade
waffles called didn't just stop with
that play from overwatch to League of
Legends
to dota wombo combo lives on over a
decade later it still stands as the
single most influential important and
hype caster call in eSports history all
right guys that's it that's the top ten
casting calls in eSports history if we
missed anything I don't care I'm gonna
go have a scoop of haagen-dazs put some
comments down below see you guys later
okay how many different ways do you
think I can say wombo combo all right
here's an Australian accent rocailles
way you ain't wait
here is a call McNeil doing wombo combo
guys guys my moustache where are you
face up wombo combo Dan rosin guys guys
where you at where are you at where are
you at
Oh Oh wombo combo wombo combo this is
Devon
guys where are you at where are you at
Oh Oh
wombo combo Oh get your ass whupped